there is a story that went viral and i
really wanted to share it when the story
popped up on our feed we like
knew we had to mate this amazing group
of musicians
um it has over 42 like million views now
so i know it's crazy a retirement
community
in uh bartlettsville oklahoma came up
with an imaginative way to keep their
residents fit
and funky with the help of a little
drumming so joining us now
we got them here we're the lucky ones
tyler watts the life enrichment director
of the
green country village senior living and
his
fabulous drumline they're here
oh my goodness hello
good morning thank you everybody for
taking the time
what inspired you to come up with this
idea you know
drew we uh we've had several exercise
classes
and here at green country village we
wanted to find something that was a
little bit different
and i had seen this class done before in
other communities
and then gyms and i thought you know we
need to bring this here to green country
village and so we bought the exercise
balls we
got the drumsticks and uh we put the
class together and
it turned into something big in fact our
very first class had about five or six
residents that came to drum
and now every class we have has at least
20 drummers
and so it's just picked up
may i ask if you could teach me
and anyone watching the show how to do
this
absolutely let's do it you want to
follow along
all right all right here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i have to tell you even when i got it
wrong i was laughing at myself
and i just had the biggest smile on my
face that was so
transportive and transformative now
tyler i know
you're a father of four kids
what can you say to parents who feel
very out of control right now trying to
juggle kids and homeschool
and staying home trapped in the homes
like
you have four kids how do you help
everybody around you feel
more in control when everything is out
of control
because you're a parent yourself and
you're doing it what's your advice
drew i guess my advice would be positive
be kind and be creative this class has
brought that to the community right it's
a little bit of silly
and right now in the world we need that
little bit of silly and for those
parents that are struggling or
for even those those senior communities
that can't find something to do
be a little creative and just find ways
to be kind to those around you
if it's something as simple as some
drumsticks and a ball that will make
people smile
and laugh that's what we need right now
so
be creative find something that's silly
i'm really glad i asked because that's
the best answer
and we are all in this boat rowing
together and i just thank you guys so
much
for coming here on this show and showing
us a way
to handle daily life in such a beautiful
fun silly but very effective way thank
you
truly thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
you